[Music]
foreign
we are going to compare the roles of
different dragons seen in Game of
Thrones and House of the dragon with a
little bit of description in between so
as to not be demonetized because you
know I gotta eat and maybe sometimes
take my girl out for dinner so let's get
into it
the first one air acts this young
juvenile dragon is white in color and it
is one of the quieter dragons in House
of the Dragon
it has a very low tone roll that doesn't
stretch out for a long time rather it
has it in short bursts with cackles in
between
the next one Vermax the green dragon is
only hurt when it was a juvenile Dragon
a small one in the dragon pit but yep it
was a sight to see
[Music]
it has quite a range of vocals from
cackles to screeches and also sort of a
sore stretch out Roar
the next one Cyrax this Noble she dragon
has a very clean role that isn't really
very high pitch or low either but
somewhere in between
and her Rose resemble that of a mix
between a large-sized bird and a male
African lion in a way
[Music]
now we have caraxis the blood worm of
Prince Damon was a deformed Dragon and
also his Roar has the highest pitch of
all these dragons from House of the
Dragon
[Music]
he has a dual sound of vibrating Roar
couple with a screech and a whistling
high-pitched sound that comes out in
fast regular intervals foreign
[Music]
this Dragon when it was turned by the
ninth King into an under dragon
developed a very different type of Roar
as compared to drogons or rhaegars
it is a form of broken cackles and
broken high-pitched screeches that makes
it sound sinister
next we have drogon the black dragon of
Daenerys Targaryen was the biggest among
the three and no doubt has the best
sounding Roar in my honest opinion from
both series
the raw sounds really developed and
masculine which feels like a heavy
Furniture being dragged on the floor
made of fiery tiles and lava
next we have melees the Red Queen with
the red head and a crown of horns has
one of the best sounds from House of the
Dragon
melees is a highly mature female dragon
roar with a mix of a low tuned raw mix
with a high-pitched full Screech
[Music]
[Applause]
dream fire this she Dragon was seen
slightly in the episode of Eamon and the
Ping Fury her role sounded like a
wholesome singular low tone but with a
bit of static overlay
next we have vermouth the bronze Fury
has a very mixed low tune sounding role
which is kind of a mix between a raw and
bass cackles along with a sort of a low
sounding growl
[Music]
its growl is a very low frequency and
makes him sound like an old Dragon which
has a lot of pent up energy stored for
the next fight
foreign
vegar this is the biggest of the living
dragons and he has a very dinosaur in
face with a long snout but she is very
old and therefore her Roar isn't as
iconic
heror actually however gives off a kind
of a lazy feel kind of like a cow or a
bull like a moo when she is in rest and
has a short low tune Roar when excited
as seen in storms end of the baratheons
foreign
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the dragon rolls do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel till the next one take care
fam